sono quasi un milione e 400 mila i morti
sulle strade del mondo dovuta incidente
stradale è come se ogni anno una città
come milano scomparisse ed è come se 10
boeing 747 pieni di persone cadessero
ogni singolo giorno dell'anno questo per
dare un'idea del problema da una
dimensione un problema c'è un altro
numero che è ancora più impressionante è
questo
quasi il 93 per cento degli incidenti
stradali è dovuto a cause umane cioè non
è il veicolo che si rompe non è la
tecnologia ma il guidatore il guidatore
che non è capace di guidare che si
distrae che guida sotto l'influenza di
sostanze questo il problema
e qualcuno è pensa che la soluzione a
questo sia la tecnologia infatti noi
stiamo lavorando sulla tecnologia per
portare una soluzione al problema degli
incidenti stradali
l'obiettivo è quello di avere un aiuto
al guidatore addirittura qualche cosa
che rimpiazzi il guidatore avere un
guidatore elettronico e che prenda il
controllo del veicolo e il guidatore
elettronico chiaramente non si distrae
non beve sempre attento reagisce
velocemente
questo è quello che noi e anche altri
stiamo cercando di fare ormai da direi
una ventina d'anni questo che vedete è
un filmato che mostra uno dei nostri
test una nostra campagna di test e ad
esempio qui eravamo in città a parma e
in un ambito stradale normale in un
vicino a pedoni e biciclette con
semafori rotonde insomma tutto quello
che si fa normalmente in una guida
urbana e extraurbana e anche addirittura
in in autostrada questo è uno dei
sistemi che abbiamo che abbiamo
sviluppato questo è un veicolo se ce ne
fossero tanti di veicoli magari tutti
che avessero questa tecnologia
cioè capacità di guidare in modo
automatico beh se ce ne fossero tanti
probabilmente avremo una mobilità molto
diversa
avremo una mobilità sicura mente di
micio diversa più sicura ma anche più
efficiente efficiente non soltanto dal
punto di vista dell'uso del carburante
ma anche dal punto di vista della
efficienza temporale del tempo il timbro
di cemento arrivare a destinazione
oppure dal punto di vista dello spazio
quanto tempo quanto riesco a
impacchettare le macchine perché queste
possano magari sfruttare meglio
l'infrastruttura stradale e non
costruire ad esempio nuove strade e ai
vantaggi sono tantissimi oltre
ovviamente a quello principale è quello
del della miglior migliorare migliorare
il traffico e la mobilità
noi di solito ci ci dimentichiamo che
quando ci mettiamo al mattino sulla
nostra macchina pronti per guidare siamo
accingendoci a fare una delle attività
più pericolose della nostra giornata che
appunto la guida e se noi un giorno
riuscissimo ad avere un sistema
automatico che prende il controllo del
nostro veicolo lo mantiene
e ci porta a destinazione beh saremmo
riusciti avere un sistema robotico che
risolve uno dei problemi principali e
più diffusi complessi e soprattutto
pericolosi per l'uomo
ci sono già sistemi robotici che
attualmente lavorano con problemi
pericolosi e risolvono problemi
pericolosi penso ad esempio all'interno
delle aziende è però in quel caso il
sistema robotico interagisce con
personale addetto personale addestrato
nel caso del veicolo automatico e una
foto diversa perché il veicolo deve
interagire con le persone di tutti i
giorni deve interagire con il mondo
comune deve interagire con
nel mondo diciamo normale e una svista o
un errore di interpretazione una
percezione sbagliata dell'ambiente
potrebbe davvero influire sulla vita o
la morte dei personaggi che sono a bordo
le persone che sono a bordo i passeggeri
sono soggetti alle decisioni del veicolo
questo è un problema molto grosso perché
il veicolo automatico avrà la
possibilità di decidere se la persona
che a bordo vivrà o no e le decisioni
che in volvo che coinvolgono la vita
umana sono tipicamente devono dovrebbero
essere gestite da da considerazioni
etiche e di questo voglio parlare oggi e
considerazioni che ho portato un esempio
supponiamo di essere in questa
situazione cioè dove il nostro veicolo
si sta muovendo sull'autostrada poco
traffico c'è una situazione normale
veicolo in grado di percepire le linee
peggiorate sulla carreggiata e le
barriere che ci sono ai lati i veicoli
che sono le infonde addirittura anche
l'ostacolo che abbiamo vicino veicoli in
grado di percepire queste cose con i
suoi sensori e chiaramente vedere c'è un
ostacolo è la prima cosa da fare
direi e provare a frenare ci sono anche
altre manovre però c'è una decisione da
prendere
la prima è la frenata la seconda magari
potrebbe essere per fare un'altra
manovra che potrebbe essere la
pianificazione di una manovra evasiva ad
esempio mi sposto sulla carreggiata
procedo tipo e riporto in questo caso è
vito l'ostacolo però per fare questo per
farlo in modo sicuro mi serve
qualcos'altro mi serve la percezione o
capire veicolo deve sapere che dietro
non arriva nessuno né c'è una distanza
ragionevole con l'ostacolo le velocità
tra le attive lo permettono cioè deve
avere una percezione molto ben
dettagliata e densa dell'ambiente
circostante ma non è sufficiente
non è sufficiente per fare in modo che
il veicolo si comporti bene come dicevo
prima sarà qualcos'altro
e tutte le volte che si lavora con
sistemi così complessi come questo
servono delle campagne di a
posizione e teste estreme
bisogna percorrere migliaia migliaia e
migliaia e migliaia di chilometri per
riuscire a esporre il nostro veicolo al
maggior numero di scenari possibile noi
cinque anni fa abbiamo percorso con i
nostri veicoli automatici il tragitto
che va da parma fino a shanghai ed era
stato il primo è ancora ultimo facciamo
l'unico test di guida automatica così
lungo intercontinentale e abbiamo
imparato tantissimo abbiamo imparato
tantissimo abbiamo esposto al nostro
sistema il nostro i nostri veicoli a
tantissimi ambienti diversi tantissimi
scenari di vedersi ma non è sufficiente
non è sufficiente ancora dice serve la
sensoristica serve beh insomma esporre
il sistema a scenari diversi
serve ancora qualche cos'altro serve
quello che dicevo prima come l'etica del
veicolo
un esempio parla di questa situazione
questa è una situazione diciamo
abbastanza tradizionale normale siamo
nessuna carreggiata una strada a doppia
corsia
c'è un veicolo che sopraggiunge dalla
parte opposta in direzione opposta
ci sono un paio di persone che
passeggiano tranquilli e sul marciapiede
veicolo vede questa situazione riesce a
gestirla non c'è nessun problema con
certo punto uno dei pedoni decide di
attraversare la strada il veicolo vedo
capisce capisce che sia il problema
localizza il pedone localizza la
distanza conosce tutto perché a questa
sensoristica molto avanzata per non ce
la fa a frenare perché la velocità
troppo alta
non ce la farebbe a frenare senza
impattare contro pedone allora cosa si
fa beh ci sono allora la prima scelta è
quella di frenare impattare contro
pedoni ma c'è un'altra possibilità
un'altra possibilità potrebbe essere
sterzo tutto a destra salvando la vita e
la vita al pedone in altra grattamento
però diciamo impattando contro due
pedoni che stanno passeggiando
tranquillamente e lungo il marciapiede
oppure un'altra possibilità potrebbe
essere quella di sterzare tutto
dall'altra parte mister sa tutto a
sinistra e salvando di nuovo la vita il
pedone attraversamento però impattando
contro veicolo che procede in direzione
opposta
quindi mettendo a repentaglio la vita
delle persone che sono sul veicolo che
magari anche la vita delle persone che
sono sull'altro veicolo che procede in
direzione opposta l'iperspazio non c'è
quindi queste sono le uniche tre
possibilità ma come possibilità che
abbiamo qual è la migliore chi devo
sacrificare l'uno l'altro ove l'altro
ancora difficile molto difficile e direi
quasi impossibile dare una regola una
risposta a questo un operatore umano
cosa farebbe un guidatore umano che cosa
farebbe in questo caso beh il mio atto
romano non è stato addestrato per per
risolvere questi problemi quando fatto
scuola guida nessuno mi ha insegnato
come dovrei comportarmi in una
situazione del genere reagisce d'istinto
che generalmente non è il modo migliore
per soler risolvere i problemi critici e
nemmeno pensare di scegliere casualmente
nel modo migliore perché se scelgo
casualmente lo dire che sto buttando via
dell'informazione che magari avrei
potuto utilizzare per prendere una
decisione migliore invece veicolo
autonomo alla possibilità di cielo prima
di avere sicuramente un ascensore stick
avanzatissima e avere la possibilità di
percepire tutto quello che c'è intorno
lo percepisco nei minimi dettagli in
modo molto molto fine molto denso il
veicolo autonomo anche la possibilità
dicevo prima di essere avere una storia
è stato già esposto a situazioni
analoghe prima e quindi magari potrebbe
avere già una minima soluzione a questo
problema è il veicolo autonomo e il
guidatore autonomo e elettronico quindi
anche la possibilità di prendere
decisioni molto velocemente in una
frazione di secondo
quindi cosa serve ancora per dare la
possibilità al sistema di prende una
decisione in questo caso e cielo prima
l'etica cioè dobbiamo fare in modo di
spiegare al veicolo come comportarsi in
una situazione di questo tipo cioè come
rapportarsi con la vita delle persone
asimov più di 70 anni fa aveva già
definito come il robot del futuro
e dovrebbero interfacciarsi lavorare
insieme alle persone insieme agli umani
ci stiamo arrivando come ci stiamo
arrivando questo è il primo esempio di
un sistema che deve prendere decisioni
rispetto alla vita delle persone
cioè noi adesso stiamo lavorando perché
tra 50 anni i nostri figli i nostri
nipoti abbiano nella mobilità migliore
più sicura efficiente insomma migliorare
la situazione della mobilità e
sicuramente sorrideranno quando
penseranno a noi che adesso perdiamo
grande a parte del nostro tempo
diventando un volante cercando di stare
in mezzo a due righe bianche pitturate
sull'asfalto e nel fare questo perdiamo
un sacco di tempo ed è un'operazione
tremendamente pericolosa e noi siamo dei
primitivi in questo caso cioè ci
vedranno una dei primitivi e sono
convinto che il veicolo automatico
sarà il primo esempio di un sistema
robotico quindi con capacità decisionali
autonome che dovrà decidere sulla vita e
sulla morte delle persone e sta a noi
adesso adesso stiamo lavorando noi
parlano in tanti centri di ricerca al
mondo cercando di capire come dare al
veicolo una sua etica